zombie Mary Akai was a community leader
in Northern Kenya but she was killed
alongside 10 other people including
police officers two weeks ago
[Music]
they were pursuing armed Bandits who had
stolen livestock from turkana County but
were outnumbered and outgunned
she tried to get help but bled to death
from her gunshot wounds she would have
been saved by here but she lost strength
because of lack of water because there
is very little water in that area
Sacha talks among Harding communities
that border conflict areas are not new
in this part of the country
this is a village that was set up
recently Paul here say they left because
of security problems Villages that we've
been talking to say they have no foods
and they still don't feel safe
the families say they lost everything
when Bandits are talked to their home
lowen is protecting us sometimes when
there is a big attack we see police but
by that time our animals have already
been taken we are on our own
in another Village this man tells us how
cattle thieves stall hundreds of goats
ship and camels they tried to give Chase
but they only had crude weapons
cattle wrestling is a lucrative trade
that overlaps inter-ethnic conflicts
competition for water and pasture easily
accessible arms and an exploited natural
resources have made things worse we are
fighting a political war we are fighting
a war that some bigger men of this
country they really want to control our
resources and take them this one is
politically investigated and by some
greedy greedy people that are so rich
even but they really want to pursue more
resources
back at the Village young men take turns
to patrol their neighborhood they say
they want to keep everyone safe and
ensure the few animals Left Behind
during the last trade aren't stolen as
well Catherine soy Al Jazeera chokana
Northern Kenya